hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
david hume devotes an entire section
indeed number eight
to the question of liberty
and necessity in his inquiry concerning
human understanding and when we're
talking about liberty
we mean liberty of the will or liberty
of volition do we
actually have what is typically called
freedom of the will can we
choose for example between alternatives
freely or are there always
if we think about necessity is there
something necessitating
our choices and therefore our actions
like some
hidden motives in the background that
even though we might
feel ourselves to be free or think
ourselves to be free
we're not really free we're acting in a
mechanical sort of fashion going from
causes which we don't really know to
effects
our volitions in our mind treated as
other causes
for other effects the actions that we
then
do and hume actually after a little bit
of going back and forth about
you know how people should be on in the
same page about things but they they
haven't
clarified definitions and all that he
says that
everybody really is
in agreement in the doctrine of
necessity and so what is
the doctrine of necessity
uh he tells us that the
relation between cause and effect and
our idea
of necessity and causation arises
entirely from the uniformity
observable in the operations of nature
where similar objects are constantly
conjoined together
and the mind is determined by custom to
infer the one from the appearance
of the other so if you've read earlier
parts of the inquiry this is
you know sort of going over old ground
we have a
constant conjunction and then we have a
customary connection
in the mind sort of replicating that
leading us to go from
what we presume to be the cause to the
effect and we call that
cause and effect or causality or in this
case necessity the idea
is that the cause necessitates the
effect and so he tells us these two
circumstances form the whole
of that necessity which we ascribe to
matter to material objects beyond the
constant conjunction of similar objects
and the consequent
inference from one to the other we have
no notion he says
of any necessity of connection
so we can go from this
about matter to thinking about how
our minds and bodies interact
how i decide to lift my hand at this
point in time
and we can also think about the interior
operations of the mind
as well along similar lines and so he
says
all men kind of have ever allowed
without any doubt or hesitation that
these two circumstances
take place in the voluntary actions of
men and in the operations of mind
if it if that's the case it must follow
that all
human beings have always agreed in the
doctrine of necessity
and why have they disagreed with each
other
merely for not understanding each other
now
that's you know that's one way to look
at it and so we've got these two
key things that are coming up throughout
this section
constant conjunction of similar objects
we observe that
right and then inference by custom from
one
object to another easy enough to observe
in the outside world
we can also observe this in the
interactions between
our mind or whatever it happens to be
and our body
you know for instance poking myself i'm
not actually going to do anything that
hurts but
if i were to do that i certainly have a
sensation here right if i poke myself in
the eye i'd have a sensation of pain
here i just have
pressure how does that work well you
know this happens over and over again we
see babies in fact learning about their
environment through doing all sorts of
what we would later on called dumb
mistakes actually toddlers do that as
well
and what they're doing is acquiring an
understanding of causality
the interactions between material
objects and their body and their body
and their mind
similarly we can talk about our own
interior operations of our mind the way
in which the faculties operate with each
other the way our ideas are put together
so there's this constant conjunction and
then inference
in our mind by custom from one object to
another
after we've developed a kind of map of
causal relations
then we carry that around with ourselves
and we know what to expect in the future
so if i take the piece of chalk
and we're talking about something here
that we believe has absolute necessity
or at least as good as we get
uh of that in a humane world and i drop
it well
there it goes i knew that was going to
happen right nobody
thought otherwise you you weren't like
well maybe it'll hang in the air or
something like that no no
we're pretty confident about that
so why do we think that we're actually
free and that human actions
are not necessitated or human volitions
what is actually going on there you know
so one
one way of talking about this is well
we've just got our understanding about
this sort of thing mixed up
but hume also brings up another
interesting thing a little bit later on
he says that i've frequently considered
what could possibly be the reason
why all mankind though they have ever
without hesitation
acknowledge the doctrine of necessity
and their whole practice and reasoning
have yet discovered such a reluctance to
acknowledge it in words
and have rather shown a propensity to
profess the contrary opinion
why why is it that human beings not just
now
but throughout all history want to say
no i'm actually free
and you're free too well this has to do
as he says with a kind of ignorance
he says that uh if we examine the
operations of the body and the
production of effects from their causes
we find that all our faculties can never
carry us any further in our knowledge of
this relation
than barely to observe that objects are
constantly conjoined together
the mind is carried by this customary
transition from the appearance of one to
the other
to the belief of the other and then he
says
when we turn our reflections towards our
the operations of our own minds
and we ask ourselves okay what's going
on here
he says that we have motives as a matter
of fact everybody has motives
multiple motives in play at any given
time
but we don't feel and he uses that word
feel
it's very important because belief is a
matter of feeling right
we don't feel the connection between the
motive which is the cause
and the action which is the effect
so we think ourselves more free than we
are
you know great example of this is when
you talk to somebody
who's been taken in by a con man
and you ask them did you make these
decisions of your own free will
and after a bit of being ashamed and
saying no he forced me and all that
they'll probably say
yeah i'm such a dummy i did this thing i
did this thing i shouldn't have done
that
oh i feel so bad about it hume would say
well the con man was able to get the
responses that they wanted from you
because they understood how human nature
worked
and how to make suckers apart from their
money and they push the right
buttons they involve the right motives
and
actions so really you're not
uh that responsible for it you just
don't
feel the connection between those things
and so he says
when we feel no connection of the motive
and the action
we're apt to suppose there's a
difference between the effects that
result from material force
and those which result from thought and
intelligence
so that's one thing the other thing that
he talks about as well is
there's a certain regularity to human
nature but people every once in a while
do weird stuff
kind of out of the blue he calls it
going into a frenzy but he says
even that can be explained by other
motives we would just need to
dig into the psychology and the
situation of that person or maybe what's
going on in their brain
and then we could actually predict that
now he has some arguments in favor of
the doctrine of necessity
one of these is quite long and we're
going to discuss it elsewhere
in the depth that it deserves but it's
pretty straightforward he says that
human beings are pretty
similar he says it's universally
acknowledged
we should think about whether this
really is universally acknowledged but
hume says that it is
that there's a great uniformity among
the actions of human beings
in all nations and ages and that human
nature remains still the same in its
principles
and operations the same motives
always produce the same actions the same
events follow from the same
causes and we're not going to go into
depth with his examples there
but this is a big assertion there's this
uniformity of human actions and motives
that means that we can actually predict
what people are going to do
based on what people have done in the
past or we can
sort of you know we can go from our
present where we observe
human beings now and if we want to
understand why ancient romans did the
things that they did
or some far-off people in a land that
we've never been to
act the way that we do we just project
what we know about human nature
on to them and if that's the case then
we really do have
some support for this doctrine of
necessity
another thing that he talks about that's
really quite interesting is what he
calls the mutual dependence
of human beings meaning that
we the things that we do this is sort of
a pragmatic argument
the things that we do are
um assuming that other people are going
to behave
in reliable predictable ways he says the
mutual dependence of men is so great in
all societies
scarce any human action is entirely
complete in itself or is performed
without some reference to the actions of
others
which are requisite to make an answer
fully the intention of the agent so when
i want to do something
and anybody else is involved in it i
don't assume that their actions are
totally random
or just willful i assume that they're
going to operate according to certain
you know rules and causes so he says
the poorest artificer who labors alone
expects at least the protection of the
magistrate
to ensure him the enjoyment of the
fruits of his labor he expects when he
carries his goods to market and offers
them at a reasonable price he'll find
purchasers
and shall be able by the money he
acquires to engage others to supply him
with those commodities
which are requisite for his substance so
we live within a matrix of
other people's actions and motives right
another thing that he points out here's
another consideration
is that if we didn't have a regularity a
predictable regularity if we understand
the motives of human beings for um
human actions if we didn't have that he
says what would become of history
had we nodded dependence on the veracity
of the historian according to the
experience which we've had of mankind
how could politics be a science if laws
and forms of governments
had not a uniform influence on society
where would be the foundation of morals
if particular characters had no
determinate power
to produce particular sentiments and if
these sentiments had no constant
operation
on our actions and with what pretense
could we employ our criticism on any
poet
or polite author if we could not
pronounce the the conduct and sentiments
of his actors either natural
or unnatural you know if we want to have
all of these disciplines
we have to have necessity necessity of
actions and volitions right
the last thing that he says which has
always stuck with me since i read it
is this uh because of the example that
he has
um he says when we consider how aptly
natural and moral
evidence the things that we're actually
seeing link together
and form only one chain of argument we
shall make no scruple to allow that they
are of the same nature
and derived of the same principles
here's the example that i love
a prisoner who has neither money nor
interest discovers the impossibility of
his escape
as well when he considers the obstinacy
of the jailer
as the walls and bars with which he is
surrounded
and in all attempts for his freedom
chooses rather to work on stone and iron
of the one than upon the inflexible
nature of the
other so in some respects
human beings can even be more
predictable than stone
or iron if we know the motives if we
know the manifold the matrix
of the motives that are you know
impinging upon what we call their
will or volition and then producing the
actions or in this case the inaction of
not letting the person
out so hume is saying everything that we
do
is really necessitated it's just
sometimes the case that
we don't feel it to be so and that's
largely because we don't actually
understand the connections between
motives and actions but everything
is as far as the will goes necessitated
this is the
doctrine of necessity
you